où
[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle édition de
parlement hebdo le meilleur de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec à mes côtés oriane machine bonjour
bonjour kata est notre invité cette
semaine laurence rossignol bonjour vous
êtes sénatrice socialiste de l'oise et
vous êtes également ancien ministre d
famille de l'enfance et des droits des
femmes est au menu du parlement cette
semaine les sénateurs examinent le
budget de la sécurité sociale ils ont
retoqué une des mesures phares la hausse
de la csg pour les retraités
la réforme du parlement voulue par
emmanuel macron est sur les rails gérard
larcher a lancé des groupes de travail
au sénat cette semaine pour la mettre en
oeuvre
et puis faut-il une nouvelle loi pour
fixer l'âge du consentement sexuel
la question est posée nom de code plfss
comme projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale le texte est à l'ordre
du jour du sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en les sénateurs ont voté plusieurs
mesures déjà adoptées par les députés
comme la suppression du rsi ou
l'abaissement des charges sociales en
gorge l'augmentation de la csg a été
retoqué explications de samir déchire
c'était la mesure la plus controversée
du plfss le projet de loi de finances de
la sécurité sociale le gouvernement
proposait d'augmenter la csg la
contribution sociale généralisée de 1,7
point pour les retraités adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale la mesure a été
rejetée mardi par les sénateurs
je ne suis pas hostile à une convergence
progressive de la csg des retraités et
des actifs mais cette hausse n'est pas
une convergence
elle est perçue comme injuste et
punitive notamment pour les tranches
supérieures qui ne bénéficient pas de
compensations notamment par la taxe
d'habitation
le reste du texte en revanche n'a pas
été sujet à polémique
mercredi les sénateurs ont validé la
transformation du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi
le cic est jugée inefficace sera
remplacée en 2019 par une baisse des
cotisations sociales pour les
entreprises
les allègements de cotisations
patronales qui interviendront en 2019
toucheront en priorité les bas salaires
c'est un moyen direct une mesure
supplémentaire pour renforcer la
compétitivité de la production française
et favoriser l'embauché de nouveaux
salariés
autre mesure concernant les charges
sociales le sénat a approuvé dans la
foulée la suppression du rsi le très
décrié régime social des indépendants
ils passeront au régime général au plus
tard en 2020
enfin jeudi les sénateurs ont dit oui à
la modification de plusieurs taxes
celles sur le tabac va augmenter le
paquet de cigarettes passera
progressivement à 10 euros d'ici 2020 la
taxe soda quant à elle sera désormais
modulée en fonction du taux de sucre
contenu dans les boissons les sénateurs
en ont profité pour supprimer une autre
taxe
celle sur les eaux minérales jugée
incohérente
laurence rossignol le sénat a donc
rejeté la hausse
1,7 point de la csg pour les retraités
est ce que c'est une bonne chose selon
lui parce que c'était une mesure très
injuste considéré que la solidarité doit
se faire entre les retraités et les
actifs
d'autant que les actifs vont avoir une
compensation par la baisse des
cotisations sociales donc une
augmentation du net sur la feuille de
salaire mais les retraités eux ne sont
pas bénéficiaires d'une mesure identique
donc la [__]
l'augmentation de la csg pour les
retraités c'est une perte sèche de
revenus aux deux pour ceux qui sont au
dessus de 1200 euros
je considère pour ma part que 6200 euros
du fait de la moyenne des retraites peut
être considérée comme une retraite su
plus tôt plus élevé que la moyenne
oui mais comme moyen de vivre et comme
capacité de pouvoir d'achat ça reste
faible 1200 euros donc c'est une mesure
injuste d'autant que les pointes de
répartition des richesses en france et
dans le monde ne sont pas entre les
actifs et ceux qui ont été actifs avant
eux
c'est entre ceux qui eux profitent à
fond de la mondialisation la
financiarisation de l'économie et ceux
là ont par ailleurs été bien servi par
le gouvernement avec à la fois la
diminuer la modification de dsf qui
devient maintenant un impôt
exclusivement sur le patrimoine
immobilier et n'est plus un impôt sur
les actifs financiers en particulier où
la flat tax
donc c'est très injuste la part du
gouvernement de vouloir faire financer
par les retraités ou par les familles on
en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure avec
la diminution de la page
les énormes cadeaux fiscaux qui sont
faits à 10% de la population justement
la page la prestation d'allocations
versées pour aux parents d'enfants de
moins de 3 ans alors on nous a entendus
dans l'hémicycle du sénat cette semaine
nous vous y avait eu un échange assez
musclé avec le vif avec la ministre de
la santé agnès buzyn donc le projet du
gouvernement c'est de baisser cette
allocation sans entrer dans les détails
en tout cas il se il dit vouloir faire
une mesure de simplification qui va être
bonne pour les familles vous c'est pas
du tout votre avis qu'est ce que vous
reprochez aux gouvernants vous qui avez
été ministre
la page cette prestation est versée déjà
sous conditions de ressources dans les
familles qui ont trente mille euros de
revenus annuels
le
baisse le plafond à 26 mille euros ça
veut dire que 150 mille familles qui
gagnent entre 26 mille euros et 30 mille
euros c'est papa même des gens on peux
pas l'aider montrés du doigt comme étant
les profiteurs de la société française
vont perdre et à la joie des familles
riches vont perdre cette allocation
et puis une autre mesure qui est un
alignement de prestation qui va faire
baisser la prestation de 15 euros
donc ça c'est ouf j'étais ministre ce
qui par ailleurs à des mesures que je
soutiens en particulier en faveur des
familles monoparentales des mesures
nouvelles ce que j'ai dit à la ministre
c'est que d'abord si elle pouvait fermer
mesures nouvelles c'était parce que nous
nous avions fait des économies et
ramener le budget de la caisse
d'allocations familiales de prestations
familiales à l' équilibre ce qui lui
permet de poursuivre ce que j'avais déjà
engagées c'est à dire une réelle
réajustement d'appétit fais mien en
faveur des familles monoparentales et
que par ailleurs les économies que nous
avions fait par la modulation et pour
être les choses un peu crûment
on a fait plusieurs du travail quand on
a fait la modulation des avocats dont
vous êtes énervé
non ne me suis pas énervé j'étais très
calme j'ai simplement dit que cette
mesure ne me paraissait pas nécessaire
ou qu'elle était injuste et que ce
n'était pas elle n'était pas utile ni
budgétairement ni socialement et je lui
ai demandé pourquoi elle n'avait pas
choisi d'aligner sur le plafond le plus
élevé est pourquoi il choisissait de
faire sortir 150 mille familles il
n'était pas nécessaire de faire des
nouvelles économies dans la branche
famille cette année grâce au signal on
va maintenant parler de l'une des
prochaines réformes voulues par emmanuel
macron la réforme du parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était une des promesses de campagne
d'emmanuel macron réduction du nombre de
parlementaires limitation du cumul des
mandats dans le temps introduction d'une
dose de proportionnelle
cette semaine gérard larcher a mis cette
réforme sur les rails en constituant des
groupes de travail mais attention les
sénateurs ont leurs lignes rouges
elodie grégoire gérard larcher a débuté
une série de consultations ce matin sur
la réforme institutionnelle le président
du sénat a rencontré les présidents de
groupe afin d'étudier leurs différents
points de vue pour l'instant deux lignes
rouges se dessine le non cumul des
mandats dans le temps et la baisse du
nombre de sénateurs
la baisse du nombre de sénateurs ne
devait pas être supporté par les
territoires les plus fragiles
nous sommes une chambre qui représente
les territoires c'est l'article 24 de la
constitution
par conséquent il faudra que si on
s'accorde pour la baisse du nombre de
sénateurs
il faudra aussi s'accorder sur le mode
de désignation des sénateurs et sur la
représentation des territoires qui sont
fragiles d'un point de vue démographique
est pas question que cette réforme se
fasse sur le dos de cette france
périphérique pour françois patriat un
compromis peut être trouvé sur la
question du non-cumul des mandats dans
le temps
cette limite des noms peu longtemps
qu'il te plaît aujourd'hui au chef de
l'état
on ne peut pas faire plus de deux
mandats airbus doit s'appliquer
peut-être une autre forme en tout cas
pas pour les petits mandats locaux n'ont
fait pour les grands mandats à condition
une seule condition c'est qu'il faut
compagne d'un véritable statut de l'élu
le gouvernement reste optimiste pour une
réforme de la constitution cours en 2018
dès la semaine prochaine gérard larcher
devrait recevoir une nouvelle fois les
présidents de groupe pour au total une
dizaine de réunions jusqu'en janvier
prochain dans son signal est ce que vous
allez la voter la soutenir cette réforme
a coûté à cette étape je n'en sais
strictement rien mais il ya quelque
chose qui me trouble dans la méthode qui
est choisie en fait on jette 2 de
propositions qui certes est un brownie
président de la république mon fait mais
d'autres choses que dans son programme
et qui sont pas mises en oeuvre et où
qu'ils sont hors différé donc c'est pas
un argument suffisant pour dire qu'on
doit tous s'incliner devant c
fois la baisse du nombre étonnant de
parlementaires et pas simplement du
nombre de sénateurs et la question du
cumul des mandats dans le temps or la
bonne méthode c'est partir du diagnostic
quel est aujourd'hui l'état des lieux de
la démocratie française
qu'est ce qui fonctionne bien qu est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas bien et puis après
en fonction du diagnostic ont frein il
faut faire des propositions et faire
évoluer la démocratie jeu j'observe en
particulier sur l'action du nombre la
région de droite parlementaire pour moi
c'est une proposition populiste
voilà tout ce qui est plus populiste il
ya aujourd'hui une grande défiance à
l'égard des élus qui tient davantage à
mon sens à notre incapacité collective
et depuis 30 ans à réduire résoudre la
question du chômage c'est dire que les
gens pensent qu'on ne sert à rien parce
que on ne change pas de sujet central
qu'à l'action du chômage donc dû couler
comme les élus servent à rien et on
pensera toujours de trop on peut changer
le nombre sûr mais si on est inefficace
et on aura toujours de trop pour les
gens donc c'est une mesure peu plus de
finale justin à 100 je ne crois pas un
instant que la baisse du nombre des
parlementaires va ramener aux urnes
des gens qui s'en sont éloignés je n'y
crois pas et je pense par ailleurs qu'on
a des injonctions contradictoires nos
citoyens attendent de nous qu'on soit
très présent sur le terrain quand il
voit les photos de l'assemblée ou du
sénat avec des rangs un peu dispersé et
10 mais qu'est ce qu'ils font et quand
on n'est pas avec eux au quotidien sur
le terrain ils nous disent qu'on est
absent
donc là on a un vrai sujet c'est comment
on articule tout ça et c'est pas en
étant moins nombreux qu'on va répondre à
ces questions là qu'en étant moins
nombreux vous serez que si vous êtes au
moins nombreux fous seraient moins
efficaces et que le lien qui existe
entre les représentants de la nation où
les représentants des territoires
sénateurs que vous êtes va se distendre
mais je dise quelque chose je dis
surtout que - du moins démocratique je
dis surtout que moins nombreux on
retrouvera les mêmes sujets qui sont des
sujets qui tiennent un peu au contrôle
de ce qu'on fait quand même je ne suis
pas favorable au mandat impératif mais
comment rencontre comme on a ce
ciné-concert nos concitoyens à des
décisions qui sont des décisions qu'on
n'a pas forcément été indiqué dans les
programmes de campagne comment la
démocratie vivante peut s'exprimer
la proportionnelle c'est une c'est une
une piste et c'est une piste
intéressante mais elle ne suffit pas
aujourd'hui pour résoudre des points des
mots cas sur les incitations du nom
demanda dans le temps si gérard larcher
il ya 13 mois j'y suis plutôt favorable
d'autant que ce que j'ai observé c'est
que le premier mandat on met des choses
en route on apprend le deuxième on
réalise et le troisième on confirme ce
qu'on a voulu faire et on n'est plus
forcément en situation pour réexaminer
son bilan et évoluer donc qu'on arrête à
trois mandats même par une bonne chose
puis d'autant qu'on nous reproche
souvent d'être des professionnels de la
politique
c'est sûr que au boot avec trois mandats
on devient des professionnels encore que
je veux dire une chose sur des toiles de
professionnels c'est qu'on n'est pas des
professionnels dans tous les cas ça nous
occupe
ça nous prend tout notre temps voilà on
a beaucoup de mal à faire autre chose à
côté et la niveau de technicité exigé
est aussi très élevé donc on peut pas
être des dilettantes de la politique
n'ont pu y avait une ligne rouge que
vous mettriez dans cette réforme là là
quelle serait-elle
écoutez moi du tout touché la ligne
rouge c'est l'absence de tête des lieux
voilà c'est la méthode et bien c'est
clair on va passer à notre troisième
thème un thème connaissez bien l'âge du
consentement sexuel qui divise les
députés
[Musique]
le débat a été relancé ces derniers
jours avec l'acquittement d'un homme
accusé de viol sur une fillette de 11
ans la ministre de la justice a été
interpellé mardi lors des questions au
gouvernement explications de stéphanie
des pierres à partir de quel âge peut-on
considérer qu'un mineur et sexuellement
consentants le débat a été déclenché
mercredi après l'acquittement d'un homme
accusé de viol sur une enfant de 11 ans
la cour d'assises de seine et marne a
estimé qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
contrainte
plusieurs députés réclament un
changement de la loi
ce verdict laisse donc à penser qu'une
enfant de 11 ans peut avoir librement
consenti à ce rapport sexuel nous sommes
bouleversés mais c'est aujourd'hui le
droit qui doit être bouleversé il faut
créer un seuil de présomption de non
consentement et le porter à l'âge de la
majorité sexuelle 15 ans pour qu'il y
ait un âge en dessous duquel le
discernement et le consentement ne
puisse être invoquée le haut conseil à
l'égalité préconise un seuil à 13 ans la
ministre de la justice confirme que les
réflexions sont en cours
la question effectivement qui est
aujourd'hui posée c'est celle de
l'établissement d'un seuil en deçà
duquel le consentement du mineur est
présumé ne pas exister
beaucoup de pays européens ont établi
cette règle avec des seuils d'âge
différent qui varient globalement entre
13 et 15 ans nous sommes nous sommes en
train de réfléchir au meilleur âge
possible évidemment nous le ferons avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
déjà en septembre une précédente affaire
judiciaire avait créé la polémique
une députée les républicains avaient
déposé une proposition de loi pour fixer
l'âge du consentement pour un rapport
sexuel
lemmy 14 ans mais voilà c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est plus de l'ordre du
ressenti que de l'analyse scientifique
et je pense qu'il pourrait être
intéressant de consulter des
associations
juge des gens qui ont
professionnellement l'habitude d'être
confrontés à ce genre de problème pour
réfléchir à quel âge on fixe cette
limite soit le débat devra être tranchée
rapidement les ministres de la justice
et de l'égalité femmes hommes ont promis
de définir cet âge du consentement
sexuel dans la loi contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles prévue en 2018
voilà la fixation de dubeau nash et je
peux dire divise les parlementaires est
ce que vous comprenez que ce type de
débat puisse faire division tout ça ne
devrait pas être le cas bien sûr mais on
peut peut-être éviter de faire comme sur
tout sujet un débat binaire avec les
partisans du 13 ans les partisans du 15
ans les uns et dans les amis des
violeurs et les hôtes les protecteurs
des enfants c'est pas ça le sujet moi
j'ai déposé une proposition doit aussi
sur la question du consentement et
d'autres sujets relative à la protection
des mineurs en matière de violences
sexuelles
j'ai mille seuil de 15 ans j'ai mis 15
ans parce que contrairement à ce que dit
la députée qui posait la question il ya
un instant il n'y a pas d'âge de la
majorité sexuelle
on déduit du code pénal qui fixe à 15
ans l'âge auquel il y à une présomption
d'atteinte sexuelle c'est à dire que
tout rapport sexuel tout rap tout
rapport entre un mineur et de moins de
15 ans et un majeur est considérée comme
étant une atteinte sexuelle sans parce
que c'est dans le caucase océans côtes
linak voit donc et c'est à partir de là
qu'on en déduit un âge d'une majorité
sexuelle mais c'est un concept faut par
ailleurs
moi j'ai aligné l'âge de présomptions
pour le viol sur celui des atteintes
sexuelles
ça m'a semblé plus simple mais je suis
tout à fait ouverte ce dont tout le
monde a peur la réalité c'est de se
retrouver dans une situation où on
aurait une jeune fille de 14 ans où un
jeune garçon de 14 ans qui vivra une
grande histoire d'amour avec un majeur
de 18 ans et là on va revenir l'endroit
moral les parents qui attaque et c'est
bon c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
si on peut le faire on aura une
condamnation pour atteinte sexuelle on
n'aura pas une condamnation de pro
violent vous allez me dire c'est moins
grave enfin quand même si une grosse
condamnation celle pour atteintes
sexuelles
moi je suis ouverte à la discussion les
pays autour de nous sont plutôt contents
parce que dieu la ministre entre 14 à
part
entre 14 et 16 et puis j'ai vu cette
campagne aux états unis je passe il vous
l'avez vu de ces femmes qui postent des
photos d'elle à 13 ans regarder à 13 ans
j'étais une petite fille j'étais pas une
fin donc il faut pas se précipiter pour
légiférer à fizi fausse précis faut pas
les enterrer
il faut il bien sûr il faut légiférer
très vite je pense que le gouvernement
j'espère que le projet de loi qui est en
préparation a déjà été transmis au
conseil d'état parce que j'avais quand
même plusieurs semaines qu'on en parle
annoncé pour le printemps
oui oui m'enfin je pense qu'on pourrait
aller plus vite moi j'aime le jeu
propose amour au gouvernement prendre ma
proposition doit jamais cette
disposition et après dans le débat
parlementaire
muriel salmona qui est la responsable de
l'association mémoire trauma fixe le
seuil à 15 ans les magistrats j'en
interrogé hier sont plutôt pour certains
autour de 14
mais je pense que sur tout ce qu'il faut
fixer c'est une règle collective tout
rapport sexuel entre un majeur et un
mineur ne peut pas être considéré comme
étant fondée sur le consentement du
mineur dès lors que ce mineur a moins de
15 ans et déjà la loi et c'est un viol
et s et ça peut être un viol s'il ya eu
pénétration avant d'accueillir jim
jarrassé du figaro on va parler d'un
sujet qui vous tient à coeur
l'environnement cette semaine avait lieu
la coop 23 emmanuel macron a prononcé un
discours lors de cette coop 23 emmanuel
macron qui accueillera également le
sommet de paris le 12 décembre est ce
que vous saluer son combat dans ce
domaine oui je salue le combat naval et
le maquereau dans ce domaine il est très
présent sur la scène internationale pour
faire vivre la corde paris et ramener
tous les pays en même temps pour parler
d' emmanuel macron je pense que je suis
très inquiète car et à la coop 23 sont
extrêmement décevant peut-on dire et je
suis inquiète au sens où je finis par
penser de manière très attristé que les
forces économiques qui dirige cette
planète et les gouvernements qui sont
bien impuissant à leurs côtés ou qui ne
veulent pas se donner la capacité de
puissants vont saigner la planète
jusqu'à sa dernière goutte c'est quand
même sac et en soirée c'est en gros ce
jour de faire comme expert météo france
c'est ça qui est en cause aujourd'hui
c'est que sans les américains
effectivement on peut faire non pas
faire et la question n'est pas simple et
c'est la question du changement de
modèle
nous ne pourrons pas continuer de vivre
comme nous vivons
et en même temps de nous protéger contre
les divers désastres environnementaux
qu'ils soient liés à l'agriculture
intensive
il faut à la fois nourrir tout le monde
faire travailler tout le monde est
protégée a fait naître c'est une c'est
une sacré équations et emmanuel macron
dit que l'europe se substituera aux
américains pour vous ce n'est pas
possible quand l'europe par le
financement dû gérer le financement
chaque bien sûr que c'est possible
européenne l'europe a les moyens de
financer le giec
mais le giec est un outil extrêmement
utile dans la lutte climatique
mais en mai il faut poser la question du
changement de modèle et j'avais tiqué
quand nicolas hulot a annoncé le report
des dates de fermeture des centrales
nucléaires n'ont pas à 100 en 2025 et
2030 vers 2030 2035 066 est reporté sine
et dié la question et parce que c'était
techniquement possible c'est qu'est ce
que ça signifie et je ne crois pas que
quand on accepte de prolonger les
centrales nucléaires ça veut dire qu'on
va être pour autant plus efficace dans
la lutte contre les émissions de carbone
et donc nous sommes confrontés au
changement de modèle et le changement de
modèle je ne vois pas j'entends quand
même beaucoup dans ce gouvernement comme
dans beaucoup de dents temps beaucoup
d'autres un discours très productiviste
très productiviste qui n'est pas
compatible avec nos ambitions en matière
environnementale dans ce rossignol c'est
l'heure de passer à la partie politique
de parlement hebdo un bon c'était bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous accueillons ginga c'est notre
partenaire du figaro bonjour
laurence rossignol bonjour plus que
jamais nous sommes charlie c'est l'appel
que vous avez lancé il ya quelques jours
dans l'hémicycle du sénat pour critiquer
ceux qui critiquent justement le lait
une de charlie hebdo sur la sphère
ramadan est ce que vous incluez dans cet
appel edwy plenel le patron de mediapart
qui bien sûr que les critiques actuelles
bien sûr d'abord être vip enel a réagi
de manière excessive
en fin de compte et du pénal ne supporte
pas non plus les une ironique et
grinçante de charlie hebdo et il n'est
pas le seul je vous rappelle quand même
juste les cookies régulièrement sont à
la une de charlie hebdo ce sont les
catholiques avec des dessins incroyable
et à chaque fois ils demandent pas ce
qu'on leur présente des excuses
donc oui du pénal a mal réagi parce que
derrière cette affaire de charlie hebdo
il y en a une autre parce que c'est lié
à la sphère tariq ramadan et le diane le
débat et j'avais interpellé
effectivement une vie pleine et à
plusieurs fins autres récemment sur dans
une autre émission c'est que edwy plenel
a fait partie de ceux qui d'abord au
cours des dernières années se sont
érigés en commandeur nous disant qu'ils
étaient bien à gauche qui était pas bien
à gauche qui était dans la bonne ligne
qu'ils étaient honnêtes qui n'était pas
honnête
bon déjà un peu de modestie parce que
edwy plenel a pendant plusieurs années
alors qu'on lui disait que tariq ramadan
était un individu ambiguë et dangereux
sur le point et de logique
il a préféré continuer de s'afficher
avec lui et c'était nous qui avons été
mis en accusation
caroline fourest moi même tous ceux qui
disaient que vous ne pouvez par exemple
mais bien sûr qu'il a fait preuve de
complaisance quand on disait quand même
problème avec tariq ramadan comment
quelqu'un d'aussi ambigu sur la
lapidation peut être considéré comme un
islamologue fréquentable et avec lequel
on peut essayer de construire ensemble
quelque chose
tariq ramadan est en dehors du cadre
républicain et ceux qui l'ont soutenu
ont été aveuglés parce que ils se sont
trompés de combat
manuel va justement a eu des propos très
durs en sept semaines contre cette
gauche qu'il accuse de complaisance avec
l'islam radical
il a dit je veux qu'il rende gorge est
ce que vous êtes chaud sur la même ligne
que lui
maintenant je parle pas faim
je suis c'est des mots très forts oui
c'est des mots très forts s'étaient pas
des mauges employés moi j'ai demandé par
exemple à edwy plenel de faire ses
excuses à caroline fourest mon l'avoir
insulté et méprisé pendant des années
malgré ce que la justesse et la véracité
de son analyse de tariq ramadan
d'abord sur ces affaires de laïcité il
faut poser les choses dans le bon ordre
première cible la droite et l'extrême
droite qui se sont approprié la laïcité
pour la dévoyée et qui en fait ne
défendent pas la laïcité mais se servent
de la laïcité pour promouvoir l'identité
chrétienne de la france ce qui est
profondément contradictoire avec aider
même de laïcité et qui veulent faire de
la laïcité une arme anti musulmans pour
promouvoir l'identité chrétienne de la
france ça ce sont les premiers qui ont
biaisé le débat après à gauche c'est
vrai que nous avons une discussion qui
n'a jamais été réellement et sainement
traité qui est en train d'exploser est
en train d'exploser parce que ce que
c'est quand on laisse le couvercle de la
cocotte minute sur la coupe est minuté
consommer et qu'on s'en va avec le feu
de soucy réconciliables aujourd'hui
c'est écoutez je la notion de tirer
quand cela ne se dirait consignables me
paraît trop définitive trop définitive
ce que j'observe c'est que pour le
moment il ya deux gauches qui ne sont
pas d'accord alors sur la manière dont
il faut aujourd'hui traiter le
fondamentaliste islamiste et qui donc je
veux juste te dire une chose les
fondamentalistes islamistes sont les
premiers adversaires des musulmans de la
république et des musulmans qui veulent
vivre dans la république
on a parlé dans socialiste cette semaine
il s'agit de tirer un marshal bac il est
accusé d'harcèlement et d'agression
sexuelle par une série de militante
socialiste est une affaire très grave et
ce que craint pour réclamer des
sanctions et une exclusion des suites
judiciaires comme le ps le fait alors
sur la question des sanctions une
première remarque si je crois que tu
irais marshall bec et déjà plus au parti
socialiste on m'a dit que tout ton
depuis deux ans donc ça tombe bien
non moi ce qui m'a énormément trouver
dans cette affaire c'est que j'ai occupé
des fonctions je suis densifier dans mon
parti comme étant une protectrice des
femmes
comment est ce possible que ce ne soit
pas jamais remonter jusqu'à mes oreilles
est ce que j'en ai discuté avec d'autres
collègues la direction provisoire du
parti ou du grand national
je veux savoir aujourd'hui
comment je veux comprendre d'abord je
veux comprendre donc être en termes
potter oui oui voila j'ai effectivement
on peut appeler ça une commune en tant
qu'interne faudra trouver un mot qui
soit plus que l'omerta là je pète la
boeufs carottes de cette affaire il ya
une omerta sur ce sujet jugé que je veux
comprendre comment est ce possible que
des comportements de ce type pas qui a
tiré marchand bègue des tirs et marshall
bec en a partout et il ya
malheureusement il y en aura encore
d'autres à la fin à l'issue de tout ça
c'est comment est ce possible qu'un
individu soumettent des femmes autour de
lui que elle ne serait elle conserve sa
pour elle même ou que ce qu'elle en
parle ne plus parler et on a tous un
problème en fait qui est une espèce de
corporatisme traque aux pourparlers très
concrètement il ya des gens qui ont
couvert selon vous cherchez le box mais
c'est ce que je veux savoir
je ne sais je ne dirais pas couverts je
pense qu'il ya des gens qui ont
probablement ont pas mesuré n'ont pas su
comment faire aussi noah - avaient été
avertis en 2015 par une militante sur le
sur le sujet il n'a rien fait a priori
c'est ce que dit la libération mais
justement quand je dis il faut qu'il ya
eu un travail d' enquête interne pour
comprendre c'est pas simplement les
responsabilités ce une affaire qui date
de 2011 2013 donc mais c'est pas ça mon
sujet mon sujet c'est comment on peut
faire pour que ça ne se reproduise pas
chez nous et chez les autres ce sera la
question de la fin merci laurence
rossignol et on se retrouve très bientôt
sur lcp public sénat ciao
[Musique]